hi guys welcome to this video
in this video we're going to be learning
django by building three different
projects
so the projects we're going to be
building are a url shortener
a to-do list app and an english
dictionary
so without wasting any of your time let
me show you the demo of everything we're
going to be building
so the first one i have here is the url
shortener so let me show you how this
works
if i go to google and i search for a
term like python
once i click on enter you see that it
gives me this link
to the search page but the link is very
long
now if i come here and then paste that
link
in here let me just remove this and
click on shortened
you see that generates this link for me
this shorted link
now once i copy this shutting link and
then go open it
in a new tab you see it automatically
redirects me back
to the link which i shortened now that's
how the url shortness going to work
now the next app we're going to be
building is the to-do list app
now let me show you how the to-do list
app is so if we come here
you're going to see a jungle to-do list
app
this is what we're going to be building
and we're going to host all the apps in
which i'm talking about
so how this works is you can add a to-do
list
so let me say something like get a drink
i click on add you'll see that it
automatically adds it to those list
and once i click on delete right here
it automatically deletes it from the
list so that's what we're going to be
building
and the third one we're going to be
building is an english dictionary so if
i come here
and i search for a word like english
once i click on search it's going to
give me the meaning
the synonyms and the antonyms so you see
the meaning of the word
the synonyms of the word and antonyms of
the word
now let me search for something else
like set once i click on search
it's also going to give me the meaning
of the word a whole bunch of synonyms
and antonyms that's what we're going to
be building
now i must say that we're going to
deploy all the projects in which we're
building
and i'm going to link the source code to
all this project in the description
below
so if you're stuck you can easily follow
up and you can get all the html files
and the templates we are using
through the source code in the link
below and if you like more tutorials
like these
don't forget to check out my channel at
goodwithtomy having that said
let's go straight into the tutorial
[Music]
so guys in this tutorial session we're
going to be building
a url shortener using django so the
first thing we need to do as always is
to make sure that we have django
installed
i'm just going to say beep install
jungle
and then this command line is going to
install django on my computer
but since i already have django
installed it's going to tell me
something like requirement already
satisfied
as you can see but for you you should go
ahead and install that
so let's just create our django model
say django
admin let's say start
project and then let's name it url
shortener
so now we have created a new project
named url shortener let's just go into
that project
so in here i'm going to create a jungle
app
so i'm going to say django admin
start app and let's name it shortener
[Music]
so this is going to start a django app
name shot now if i press d i
out i'm going to see short now so now
that we have our project setup we're
just going to import it in visual studio
code
so let's come here and then what we just
need to do is to open folder
and then we're going to go into that
folder
so right here is the folder and select
folder
now it's going to open this my django
project in this code editor
so we can code so now that we have this
opened
what we just need to do is to set up our
project
so the first thing we need to do is to
create a new folder
and name it templates now in this
template folder
what's going to be in there is the html
pages in which we are going to be using
in this project
but before i continue i have my html
page here which is index.html
i'm just going to drag it into visual
studio code
and i'm gonna put it in template so let
me say once again that i'm gonna link
everything we're gonna use in this
tutorial i'm gonna link the source code
in the description below so you can
check them out to get any file you need
now that we have these we're just going
to come into our url short now
go into settings.py and then we're going
to come down
the first thing we need to do is to add
our app which is shortener
now that we've added that we're going to
come down
into templates and we'll look for this
i'm just going to say based there
i'm going to say slash templates so what
this does
is that it tells jungle we have to look
for all our templates file
and as you know we saved it in our base
directory
in a folder called templates which we
created right here
let me save this settings.py and close
it
now i want to do the url mapping if i
run my project now what you are going to
see
is jungle default template so we want to
show
our own html template first to do this
we are going to come into our app
create a new file name it urls.py
and then we'll say from jungle
dot urls import
path and then we're also going to say
from the roots
import views now we're going to say url
patterns
should be equals to path
home safe views dot index
i'm going to give it a name of index
so now what we just need to do is come
into views and create a new function and
name it index
it's going to take a request
and then let's render our html page
which we have in here that is index.html
so say return render
request index.html
now when we save this issue
automatically use this index.html as our
own page
but not yet that's because we only did
url mapping
for our app we also need to configure it
for our
main project so we're going to come into
our main project go to urls.py
what we're going to do right here is to
import include
and then we're going to create a new
path
and then let's give it blank and we're
going to say
include shortener
dot urls i'm gonna save this
now i can cancel this now let me open a
new terminal and just run our project
so now a new terminal is being popped up
and what i'm just going to say
is python manage the py
run server now this command line is
going to run our project on the
localhost
so let's just wait for it to run our
project quickly
okay as you guys can see it's running on
our locals let's open our browser
go to our localhost and then we should
see our html page
as you guys can see we have this
beautiful html page
so now that we've taken care of
everything about the template
let's dive straight into configuring the
back end
so what i want to do is to create a
django model that is going to
save a url anytime a user imports a url
and then shorten it so let's just go
ahead and do that
let's come back to official studio code
we can close this
and in our modules.py file let's create
a new model
let's say class and let's say links
okay or let's name it urls i think
that's better
so url and we'll say models dot model
and then you should take two fields
which
is link so say models.chat field
and let's give it a max length of ten
thousand
because some links are very long and
let's give it a uuid
as a models dot character field also
and the max length of these
should just be 10. now what this is
doing is that
are very familiar with django models you
know that is the same thing as a
database
so we're creating a database named url
and it's going to have two tables
the first one is going to be link and
the second one is going to be uid so
link is going to take the url which is i
want to shorten so once the user come
here and you put a url right here
and click on shorting whatever that
user's input
should save in this link model and then
a uid should be passed to that link
that is a specific id will be passed to
that link
you guys are going to understand in a
bit so let's save this first
let's bring back our let terminal
just open the new terminal here quickly
and then let's say
python manage dot py make
migrations and then after making
migrations we say python
manage the py
migrate so now this is going to migrate
everything
into our database so now that we have
uh models migrated what i like to do is
to configure my admin interface so i can
easily see my database
so let's just say python manage the by
create super
user so now let's just use the admin
and let's also use admin right here
let's give it a password now it has
okay y and now it has created that super
user we can cancel this
if i come back here and go to slash
admin
okay slash admin it's going to prompt me
to login now once i log in with the
details in which i
created now and i say login
now you guys will see that we've logged
into our admin interface
so for now we only have two database
which is users and groups
so if i open my user database you're
going to see the admin which we just
created
but what i want to do is that under here
we should also have a new database
which should be urls so let's go ahead
and do that
we're just going to open our admin.py
and register that model
first of all we need to import the model
save from dot models
import url
right here we say admin dot site
the register now let's register that
url now once we save this and come back
here and refresh
you're going to see that that is going
to pop up right here so let's wait for
our server to load
so if we come back here and open up our
terminal
okay our server is loaded back now once
we refresh you guys can see that we now
have a new database table
which is called urls so now that we have
these
let me go to my home page once the user
just clicks
input a url clicks on shorting it should
automatically
save that url into this database and
since we're going to be using ajax
it's not going to reload this page now
you know that once you submit a form in
html it's going to take you to another
page or reload that page
but we're going to use ajax to submit
this form so once the user just
input a particular url right here
what's going to happen is once you click
on shorting
without the page reloading it's going to
be saved into this database and then
it's going to return back
a response with a unique id so let's go
ahead and do that you understand what i
mean
now we're just going to come back we're
going to come into our index.html
that is our template file
so let me cancel this terminal for now
what i want to do
is to go down into this input
so right here is this so what i'm
looking for is this
input and i want to make it a form so
let me come back
so i'm gonna say form
and then i'm gonna close it
right here
so let me just delete this
so what i was going to give this form is
an id that's the only thing
so i'm going to say id and the id should
just simply be
let me say my form or post form
now this is good and we're going to be
using a post method
so when was in the post method in ajax
we're not going to configure it right
here but we're going to configure it in
the script
so you're going to see that also in a
bit
so let me say csrf underscore
token
and save so this button let me give it a
type
let me say type should be submit so that
once they click on this button you
should submit this data
and this also should have a name let me
save it as okay it doesn't have a name
so say name should be equals to
link
so now that we have these what we just
want to do
is to come down after all our html and
create a script
let's just close that and then let's
make sure that it has the type
we'll say text slash javascript
so what we just want to do now let's
give it some indentation we're going to
say dollar sign
and then is now we're going to start
with configuring or submitting our form
so before we start doing this
let's come into our
views.pri so once the user clicks on
shorting right here we wanted to take
this to a particular url
so that url is going to be called create
so in that url
it's going to create that in our
database and then send the response here
let's do that quickly so i'm going to
come back
right here in urs.py
let's create a new url and name it
create
let's say views dot create
name equals to create let me show this
as a comma
then write in views
create request
and then let's pass for now so now let's
save this
so after doing this since we have this
url what we just want to do now is to
come here and submit that form to this
url
so once we submit this form to that url
then we're going to come back here
and then get everything in which the
user inputted and just save it into our
database
so let's do that so after saying dollar
sign
i'm going to say document
and then what i want to do is dots on
submit
so let's open a bracket submit
on submit of post form
hashtag right here
hashtag post form
now how we are getting this post form is
basically this form
so what we're saying is on the submit of
post form damage once user clicks on
this submit of this form
what we want to do let's give it a
function
so that should be outside piece comma
function
should be outside that
and let's say e
is like this so now what we just want to
do
is to say e dot prevent default
so what this e dot prevent default is
going to do is that
once a user clicks on submit of this
form it will make sure that that page
doesn't reload
so now that we have that covered let's
now use our ajax so say dollar sign
again dot ajax
and endless open curly braces
press enter then the type which is also
the method
should be posts
and then url
it should be taken to slash great
so come on and then the day time which
you want to pass into it
so let's do this and then
the link
dollar sign
hashtag link
dot value
so now we're going to say csrf
middleware
token
dollar sign and then
inputs before we say input put these
square brackets let's close that real
quick and say name
the name should be csrf let me do
where token
so that's what that does and then after
this we should say dot valve to get the
value
so we're also sending in a csrf token
so after doing this we're just gonna
come down here
and click on comma and then let's also
give it a success function
so after doing these
okay in here we're gonna say
success
and let's give it a function so that
means if everything
has been submitted successfully for now
let's leave it
blank like this
so let's just leave everything blank for
now and let's come here and make sure we
put our semicolon since we're working
with javascript
so now that this success function is
uh let me say is blank
we're going to take care of that after
we submit our form
so now let's save so since we're sending
all this data
into our create url let's go into our
create url and get those data
so right here in this views dot py we're
going to go into that function
let's remove this path and say if
request
that method
is equals to post now if they are
sending a post
method let's say url
should be equals to post
dot it should because request dot
post
link so we're getting what the user
put as this link and store it in a
variable named url
and then let's also use a uid
so once the user also stores that
variable
once the user stores that link i mean we
also want to
assign a particular id to that variable
so that we can use that id to generate a
shortened link
and once that goes to that shortening
link it should come back to this url
so it's going to make sense also let's
just import
uuid to get
a unique id so i'm going to say string
we want to make sure it's in a string so
say that uuid
does uuid 4
open bracket close bracket and then what
you just want to say
square brackets column five so what
shortening
because when this generates a unique id
it generates is very long but want to
shorten it to only
five strings so let's
save okay we don't need to save yet so
what we need to do now
is to after we get all this data we just
want to save this data in our database
first to do this we need to import our
modules we say from dot models
import url so right here now we're just
going to say
new on url should be equals to
url
dot url open bracket close bracket
and the link should be equals to the url
and then uuid
should be equals to uid now once we have
these we're just going to say
new url dot save
and then once we save these we just want
to return a response
say return http response but before we
use that we also need to import http
response
say from django.http
import http response right here
so say return an http response
of the uid
now we can save this
once we go back here and test this now
it should work
let's refresh this page now let's give
it a url
let's do something like https
then let's say www.youtube.com
slash code with tommy
okay this is slash now once i click on
shorting
nothing happens but if i come right here
and click on refresh
as you can see nothing happens again
so we need to open our inspect element
right here we're gonna come to the
network
so now let's try it again let's click on
shorting so as you can see
we have an error and this is what the
error is
okay it's giving us a jungle
error actually so let's just enlarge
these
and see so let's go and see where
the area is coming from
it's coming from right here so request
dot post link
so there is an arrow actually right here
let's see why that is giving us an error
so i'm gonna go back and just check that
let's come here so right here instead of
saying url
let's give it a link unless a link
should be equal to link and then
let's make sure everything is working
perfectly so say if request
the method is equals to post
then let's start a link should be
request
dot post link and then uid
should be string now that is nice let's
save it and go try it again
now let's close this let me just copy
the issue area i want to shorten
now let's refresh this and paste and
then
click on shorting now it gives us an
error now we're going to see
what's up okay i think it's not getting
this
link in which we are trying to give it
so let's
see let's go down again so it's not
getting linked
the program will be from index.html
so it's not getting linked we're gonna
come here
so i think the id should be linked
okay not this the id should be linked
let's save it i need to refresh
and let's click on shorting as you guys
can see now we don't have any error
again
once we come here now preview everything
is nice
so this is the uid which we are
returning as an http response right
here as you can see we return an
initiative response there's the response
it gives us if we come here and hit
refresh
we'll see that we now have a new object
the link with the uid so let's try it
again
so let's see let's just say youtube.com
and let's click on shutting
it does another one with a uid also
once you click on refresh and we come in
here
you see that link with that uid
so now what we just want to do is to
show the user the shorted link in which
we generated
so for us to do this we're going to come
right here
into our index
we want to create in this section after
the form
let's have our own div tag
and in that div tag let's create like an
h2 tag so in this http is where the link
should be for now let me put link
and refresh so see how that will look
okay it's in this shorting
so let's just bring out this away
and then put it outside here
so let's save this and see again
okay same thing so let's just remove the
div tag which we have i think there's a
styling attached to that div tag
now once we refresh it should just be a
link
okay now is there's a stanley attached
to the h2
nice so what i just want to do is to
remove this
from main and just remove this and put
it right here
let's save it and see okay it's outside
okay yes so what we just want to do now
let's try and put it here
let's hit refresh nice so we just put it
in this
section and now we can see that the link
is showing that so this is where we want
the link to show
now let's just remove this link and
leave it blank
so once we get an http response we want
to show
the link right there if i save it i'll
come back
you can see that it's blank but once
we're shutting the url we want to see
the link
pop up here for us to do this we're
going to come back to our script
where we see that success function we're
going to get the http response
now whenever we're returning an http
response for us to be able to get that
response
using ajax we're going to get it as a
variable
named data so i'm going to say data now
this data
is a variable which has the http
response stored
in it so in here
we're just going to say dollar sign
h2
and then what we just want to say is
that html
and then let's change that to
let me give it this
let's just simply change that to low
cost
8000 slash
let's add data now if i save this and go
you are going to see what it looks like
so let me refresh it let me put that
same thing
as shorting now once i shorten you see
it gives me this link
which is locales 8000 slash this uid
which was assigned
to this url so now for now we're just
using local slash because we've not
uh deployed our app to
on the web so once we deploy our once we
host our
this our app we're building on the web
we're going to use a specified link
we're not going to use localhost
8000 but i'm going to use let's say link
dot ml slash this
or just a short link but for now let's
stick with 8 000.
localhost 8 000. so now what i want to
do is that once these are now copy these
links
open a new tab and go to that link it
should take the user
back to that url in which is shortened
that's how a url short network so for
now the same page not found
let's go and do this i'm just going to
come
right here into urls
i'm going to create a new url and name
it
let's leave it blank and it take a
string it's going to be a dynamic url
and say pk so say views.let's say go
and go so let's come into views create a
new function
name it go
request
and let it also take pk so now once we
have this we're just going to get
pk and then what we just want to say
is url details
should be equals to url
dot object
dot get the one in which the uuid
is equals to pk and then let's just
return
want to redirect so we need to import
redirect right here
i'm just going to scroll down return
redirect
the user to url details dot link
now let's save this now what we're doing
is that once the user
goes to slash let me come into our
url.py
so this is a dynamic url it's going to
create something like slash
then it's going to take a string and
save it in a variable name pk so what
is that comes to slash this uid it's
gonna
this string pk is gonna be replaced and
what's
gonna be there is this id so once we now
have this id
we're gonna come into our view.py get
that id as pk
then we're not going to search for our
model
and make sure that that uid
is present in our model and a link has
been assigned to it
and then we're going to get that link so
i'm just going to say return redirect
url details dot link so i just
redirecting the user
to that link so let's save it and test
this out
so now let's refresh
okay our server is not running let's pop
it up
okay the problem is here we need to put
a comma
let's save that reload reload
so now let's refresh our app now let's
just
put www dot youtube
dot com slash code with tommy and let's
click on shorting
it gives us a url we copy it
paste it right here so now you can see
it says page not found
www.youtube.com so we need to pass this
as a url for us to do this we'll come
back here
we're gonna say https
and this now once we save it and come
back
let's copy this our page again is our
url
and paste it now you'll see that it
takes me to that page
you see it takes me to https youtube.com
so now let's come back
let's try it out with another url let's
see www
dot
and once i click on shorting it gives me
that url
let me copy it and paste it right here
now you see it takes me to
socialblade.com now that's how our url
shot now works
so i hope you guys enjoyed and
understood what we did in this video
if you did please don't forget to smash
that like button and please subscribe
thank you for watching this session
[Music]
so now that we have created our project
what we just need to do is to host our
project online
so for us to do this we're going to use
the roku as our hosting platform
so we don't need all these we can just
quit these
what we need is two python libraries
and they are unicon and django heroku so
first to install these libraries we're
gonna say
beep okay there's
beep install gunikon
and django iroku
now once i click on enter it should tell
me requirement already satisfied because
i already have it
but for you you should go ahead and
install it so you see it says
requirement already satisfied
so now that we have this installed what
i just need to do
is to come into my root directory let me
close out this
my root directory i'm going to create a
new file and name it runtime.txt
now this file should contain the python
version which you used in this project
so i use
python 3.9.1
then we're going to save it another file
we need to create is profile
so this proc file is going to create
contain these
web unicorn
web gunny con then the name of your
project which is url
shortener
dots wsgi
column application
log think a game file
and like this so we're just gonna save
it
and then after doing this what we just
need to do is to
pip freeze requirement.txt beep
freeze requirement
dot t x t
so that's done a new file here is
requirement.txt
so i'm going to come into our project
folder and go to settings.py
and up here that's right here
we're going to import
django heroku
and i'm also going to import dj database
url
and then we're going to come here into a
loud boost and make sure that we allow
all the hosts
after doing that we're going to scroll
down
and we're going to come into databases
delete this
okay delete from here
and then we're just gonna say dj
database url
dot config
so after doing this i'm gonna scroll
down to the end
all right at the bottom i'm going to say
jungle iroku
dot settings
then open brackets in that bracket i'm
going to say locales
like this so after saving this
we're good to go now we're just going to
come into our command line
and what we need to do is to log into
roku by saying heroku login
okay we type that wrong so say iroku
login now this is going to prompt us to
open our
default browser and automatically log us
in
to our roku account so let's wait for it
it should give us a reply soon
so let's type any so now our browser
should
open up so when i click on login
logged in if i come back it's
automatically logging in
now let me create a new app by saying
heroku
create and let me name it url
shortener yt
one two three just naming it a random
name
simply because i know there are there
will be
names that already have you are rational
because
in iroku you can't have you can't create
a project with a name that has already
been created before
so if i just use plain url short now it
will tell me
another person i've taken this name so
that's why i just use that randomly
so since we have this now we're just
going to say git
status
initialize
this does nice so get
remote v
then git remote add
iroku and then what we want to add
is up here this
git link just paste it and enter
and then let's say git remote v again
nice and then let's say git status nice
so what we just want to do is to create
a new
database which is heroku add-ons
create
eroku
postgres ql
rpdf
and press enter so now this should
create
a postgres database
with the ob dev version the database has
been created
so now after doing this i'm just going
to say git add
and then you should add so i'll say git
commit
let me see the first time
and then i'll say git push iroku
master
so now this git push roku master is the
final step in deploying this project
so once this is done it should
automatically deploy it
onto iroku and then we are going to get
our site url so let's wait for it to
deploy
it should deploy within a minute
depending on how
large your project is so our project is
pretty light so you should install
routine seconds so let's see
let's just wait okay installing
collected packages so what is doing now
is installing the packages which
it saw in the requirement.tx files
so let's just see after compressing it
should say
done so let's wait for it to say done
okay it says done and then now let's
wait for our final confirmation
and then we're just going to go to this
url which is the url of our project
let's wait for our final confirmation
again
okay that should pop so it says verify
deploy dot so let's just go to
this open link
now you guys can see our project is
ready so
what we want to do now before we test
our app we have to come back here
and migrate our database so say heroku
run python manage
dot py make migrations
and then after this we're going to say
hiroku run python money dot py
migrate just like how we migrate our
database when we are building our
project
so let's wait for this command line to
run it should actually say no change is
detected yes
but i just like doing that so that we
won't get any error
so my grid now
now this will migrate everything into
our database
so let's give it a moment
you should migrate that soon let's see
if i didn't do this it's going to give
me an arrow so i just have to do this to
prevent that error
okay and then done so let's come back
now
refresh so now let's try to shut in a
url
in this again now you see it gives me
locales 8000 then this link
so if i go to this url slash
this uid it's going to take me to
youtube.com slash code with tommy
but because in when we are building our
project we added this localhost so
that's because we see testing our
project
now we're supposed to add the url of
this
project which we've deployed but as you
can see we are building a url short now
if our url shortness something like this
let's say once you shut in a url
it gives you this type of url
then i don't think we are building a url
short now again so i'm going to
buy a free domain i'm going to get a
free domain
there is actually a site which allows
you to get a domain for free
so i'm going to get a free domain a very
short one and i'm going to connect it
to this our project so let me show you
the domain i'm going to get
before i show you let me test out once i
click on enter
you can see it takes me to youtube.com
slash code with tommy
now once i go back now what i want to do
i want to show you the
domain which i took so you guys can see
i already took this domain it says sorry
source.ga is not available so this is
the domain i'm going to use for this
project
source.ga for now it says source.js not
available because i already took it
so as you can see you can come in and
claim sales.cf you can claim some
domains for free
but if you want to buy the.com.net you
need to pay for them
so that's what i we're going to use in
this project so i'm just going to
connect it
with these my heroku site
so when i connect it i'll be back so
guys right now i've already connected
the domain the custom domain which i
have
to this our project so you can see now
if you go to www.source.ga
it takes you to this url shorter so
let's test out this shot now
let's test it out and click on shorten
now it gives us this url
the last thing we want to do to this
project is to update this
so instead of it saying localhouse 8000
we wanted to say www.source.ga
then slash the id so let's go and do
this we're going to come back to our
visual studio code
and then in our index.html right here
instead of saying locales 8000
let's see i think it's better if we copy
these
just come here and paste so we don't
need to put http
let's just say www.gay
www.sauce slash ga
then data so this data is the id so
let's just save this
and then what we just want to do now is
to say git add
so this what i'm teaching you now you
are going to be able to know to update
your project even after you've radiused
it
so we already have this hosted on the
web
but we want to make a change and update
it so once you make that change
to update it you just come back to your
cli and say git add
and then you're going to say git commit
iphone m
and let's say make it better
nice and then we just say git push iroku
master
now this should redeploy it again with
the updated changes
so let's just wait for that it shouldn't
take long this time
because we've already deployed it
so let's see
let's wait for it you should do within a
second
so let's see
okay
almost done after compressing you should
say
done that means it's worked
yes and now we should see deploy to your
roku so once we see this deployed to
liquid has deployed
but let's just wait for the last
confirmation before we go check
so let's wait it should say
yes done so let's go back to our browser
and then reload this page
so now let me shut in this url and click
on shorting
now if i just take this link
and copy it and paste it here
now you see that it takes me to that url
which i shortened
right here you can see that i shortened
youtube dot com slash code with tommy
then once i click on that it says
youtube.com
code with tommy so that's what this
should do
so let's try it out with another website
let's take let's go to google
and then let me just search
now this url link let me copy it
and then right here let me paste and
click on
shorten so now it gives me this link so
everything is working
perfectly
[Music]
in this tutorial session we're going to
build a to-do list app
using jungle so without wasting any time
let's get straight into it the first
thing we need to do
as always is to make sure that we have
django installed
so we should do beep install django
so since i have django installed already
it's going to tell me requirement
already satisfied but for you you should
go ahead and install django
on your computer so it's going to tell
me
as you can see it says requirement
already satisfied that is to show that i
have django
so now that we have django installed
let's just go ahead
and create our project so i'm just going
to say jungle
iphone admin start project
and let's name it to do list
now once we press enter it's going to
automatically create a jungle
boilerplate
which is a folder which contains all the
necessary files to start a jungle
project
so let's go into that folder which is
called to-do list
now if i press dir i'm going to see
money dot py and another folder called
to-do list
another thing i need to do now is to
create a jungle app
and i'm going to call this app to do so
i can just do
django
admin iphone admin start
up and i can name it to do
so once i click on enter as you can see
right now we have only
one file and one folder but now once i
check it again you see i have two
folders and one file
and the second folder which was created
is this to do which is our app
so now that we have everything set up
let's open up our project in visual
studio code so this is visual studio
code here all i just need to do
is to press open folder and then open up
my project
in the directory which i created so i
created my online to-do list directory
right here
i'm just going to select the folder and
it's automatically going to open on
visual studio code
so once it has opened now
i'm just going to quit this we just need
to configure some things which are
our template file that means the html
file which we're going to use
and then get straight into the tutorial
so to do this we're going to make sure
we're in the root directory
and then we're going to create a new
folder we're going to call our folder
templates with an s
templates and in that templates folder
i'm going to move in the html
which i'm going to use for this project
as i said i'm going to link
the description to everything that we
are doing in this video
so all the links to the source code is
going to be in the description below so
you can check that out to get all the
html css and everything we are using in
this project
so i have it right here i'm just gonna
drag it
into visual studio code
and then what i need to do is to paste
it and template now that i have this
here
i'm just gonna press cancel so what i
need to do now for django to cds
i'm going to come into my to-do list go
into settings
and once i'm in settings i'm going to
scroll down a little bit
i'm going to look for where i see
templates
so i'm going to scroll down as you guys
can see there is templates here
so where you see this you're just going
to write
base there then you're going to put a
slash
then inside there are going to put
templates this is simply telling jungle
where
all your template files are located so
after doing that we can cancel
settings now the next thing we need to
do is to come into our to-do app
create a new file called urls that's py
and in here we're just going to import
path so say from django.urls
import path so what i want to do now
since we are done with configuring the
template file and django knows where our
template is
we just want to root our url simply
means we want to provide
where our url should go to
when a user comes to our website so
you're going to understand that in a
second
so let's go to say url patterns
equals to path and we're going to leave
it blank
blank means that's the home page and i'm
going to say views dot
index and then let's give it a name
of index so
for us to use views we have to import
view so say from
root import views
so now that we are importing views we
also need to go to views
create a new function called index
it must take a request
and then we need to render that html
page which is index.html so i'm gonna
say return
okay right here i'm gonna say return
render
request
index.html
now this is going to render that index
page let me just cancel this
so once i come into urls.py
as you can see you are telling me that
once the user comes to our home
it should take the user to the views dot
index and once the user comes to that
function is just rendering the
index.html page
but if we run our project now it's still
going to show us the default jungle
template
that's simply because we only configured
our urls
in our app we didn't configure it in our
project
so if you open your to-do list project
that's the main project folder
you're going to see a url file also
so for us to configure it here we need
to import one thing called
include and then we're going to create
another path
which is also blank still means home i'm
just going to say
include
to do dot urls
now once we save this everything is fine
let's just go ahead and open a new
terminal
so right here in the new terminal we're
going to run our project
and test it in our browser so let's just
give it a few seconds okay so now
let's run our project by saying python
manage
dot py run server
so once this runs on our server
on our localhost we're gonna go open our
browser
and we're gonna see this index.html page
so what we just need to do is to copy
this
localhost come into our browser
and paste it right here so now we should
see
as you guys can see we see this
beautiful jungle to-do list app template
so now that we have everything
configured on the front end on the ui
what we just need to do is to start with
the back end
so what we want to do now is to create a
jungle model
for the to do where everything is going
to be saved and then
once the that input something right here
and clicks on add
we're going to submit it to that django
model and we're just going to show
all the objects which are in that module
and then another feature is that once
user clicks on delete you should just
delete
that object from the model it's pretty
easy so let's dive straight into it
so we're going to come right here we can
just
close this terminal and then what we
want to do is to open our modules.py
file
now we're going to create a new model
and let's just call it to do
so we're going to say models dot model
and then we only want this to just take
one field so i'm going to call
this title i'm going to say models
dot character field i'm going to give it
a max length
let's say max length of a thousand and
this should be fine
so not what this simply means is that
our model is taking only one field and
this field is the title
so if i come into this template as you
can see
this says it's the gym meet george all
these are the titles of the to-do
so that's what that field is so
all these are just dummy data for now
they are just static data
but when we integrate our database with
it they are going to be dynamic
so let's come back into our visual
studio code
and after doing this let's just return
underscore str
self so we want to return that title
return we're going to say self
dot title so we can save this
now if you know django very well you
should know that once you make
any slight change to your models file
you need to make migrations and then
migrate into your database
but before you do that you must make
sure that the app in which you are
configuring your models or py
must be registered in your settings file
so if we come into our settings right
here
we're going to go up and look for
installed apps
right here in installed apps before we
migrate our data to our database
we need to add our app which is called
to do
into our installed apps so doing this
alone we've added the app we're just
going to save it
so you must make sure that this to do
correlates with the name of your app
after saving we can cancel that so now
we're just going to bring back our
terminal
so instead of cutting this serval let's
just open a new terminal
so what we want to do is to make
migrations and migrate
so say python manage the py
make migrations
enter and then once this make the
migrations
and then we're just going to say python
manage
the py migrate
now this is going to migrate everything
we have into our database
as you can see is making all those
migrations which is good
so now that that is done let's close the
terminal
another thing i like to do is to create
a super user and configure
my django admin so i can see all the
database easily
so let's bring back our terminal and do
that
what we just need to do is to say python
manage wpy
create super user
now this is going to prompt us to put in
some details just like
if we're registering on your site so we
can just say admin
let's just give it admin
and password
so bypass that now that we have this
done
let's go ahead and test it so let's come
to our project and go to slash admin
so in slash admin you should tell us to
login so we're going to log in with
those details
so admin and also the password and just
click on login
so now you should automatically log
using into jungle admin
so right now you can see that we're
logged in in this jungle admin
so the only thing we can see in the
database is the user
and groups we also want to register our
module which we just created which is
the to do module
so for us to do this is very very easy
we're just going to come in here
we can quit this now we're going to come
into our admin dot py
file import our to-do model
so we're going to say from dot models
import to do and then let's just
register it in our admin so say
admin.site
dot register
and the naturally started to do it's
that easy
now once we save it all we just need to
do is to come back and hit refresh
now as you can see to do is already
added in our data
so once we click on it we're going to
see the list of to-do
lists the list of to-do in which we have
here
so let's say user comes into let me just
quickly go
back right here what i want to do now is
that once the user input something right
here and clicks on add
it should automatically be saved in this
database so let's go ahead and do that
now for us to do that we're going to
come back here
let's come into our views.py which is
uh which has our index function so what
i want to do is to go to our index.html
we're just going to scroll down into
where we have
what we're looking for is this form
these inputs right here
so we're going to scroll down where we
have that
so as you can see we have that right up
here
so it is an input what we just want to
do is to make it
a form so i'm just going to say form
now we're going to close it
let me first cut that and see where to
close it
so i'm going to close it right after the
span tag which is add
so i'm just going to close it right here
and then what i want to do now is to
just give this
i think some indentation
so let's just give it a little bit of an
attention so that's nice
so since this is a in a form now so guys
what i put in a form
is this input right here this input and
then this add as our submit button
so let's just go back here so what i
want to do let's make this a submit
button so say type
equals to submit
it needs to have this so says submit
now we can save this we must make sure
that this have a name
which is this one right here so say name
equals to let's say title
so let's save this so what i want to do
now is to just
make sure that once the user clicks on
add which is
serving as our submit button it should
send those data
to our index function so let's do that
so say action
let's leave it blank so it sends it back
here and let's say method
let's give it a post method we don't
need a get method
and then you know diameter wise in the
post method we must always add our csrf
token
csrf underscore token
so if i save this right now click on
refresh
once i type in something and then click
on add
okay as you can see when i click on that
nothing is happening so i think there's
a javascript right here this one click
so this javascript is colliding with it
let's save it
and try it again let's import something
and i click on add okay so it's not
serving as the button
so what we just need to do instead of
using okay let's
put this back instead of using a span we
can just change it to a button
so right here also let's change this to
a button
nice now let's go back and then refresh
as you guys can see made a little bit of
change but that's okay
so let's just input something and then
click on add
so you guys can see that it refreshed
that page so what i want to do
once you refresh that page you should
add whatever the user input
to the list of to do
right here let's go ahead and do that so
we're just going to come into
our views.py so right here in our
function we're going to use an if
statement
and that if statement we want to do is
to get even the post request
so we're just going to say if
let's give it a space so say if request
the method
is equal to post so if is equals to post
what we just want to do
is to say new underscore to do
should be equals to so before i continue
we need to import the to-do model in
which we want to save
so we're going to say from
dot models import
to do so now that we have this model we
can automatically save a data into that
model so i'm just gonna say to do
i'm gonna open a bracket and then
let's say title should be equals to
request dot post
which is title so guys what i did here
is
i assigned a new variable and what i put
inside a variable was
this to do model but i'm passing in some
fields
a field actually so this title is
basically this title we have in our
module
so this title is this title right here
so what we're giving that field is
request the post title
so while just getting this
title from a post if we come into our
index.html
we can see that once user clicks on add
it's posting this input which is named
title
into back into this page so as well
in this place we're going to collect
using that post
collecting that title this title is
whatever the user
input and then saving it into this
variable
so once we do that and then we just come
down
and click on and type new to do dot
save it's automatically going to save it
in our database
so after it's saved let's just return
let's redirect the user back to this
page before we can redirect we need to
import redirect
so let's import that so we're going to
say return
redirect the user back to the home page
now that's very easy so now let's
refresh again
no let's cancel this on it
so let's say code
so now once i click on add you see that
it refreshed and brought me back to this
page
but nothing show here because we're not
getting the list of data for now
but we come into our to do database and
click on refresh
you should see that we have one new data
now which is code which are
input so that's basically how to do it
let me go back now
let me come here do another thing and
say
go for a run
so now once i click on enter come back
here and refresh
you see that now we have a new data
called go for iran
so what i want to do now is that all
this data which we have
that's what we want to show here we
don't want all these static data
also very easy we're going to come back
into our visual studio code
so right here in our index also
what we just need to do is to get
this this to do module so we're going to
say
to do equals to to do
dot objects
dot o and then once we have this we're
just gonna pass to do
right here into our index.html
so say to do should be to do
now once we save this right here in our
index.html
we're going to come down here and use a
for loop
what we need to do now we can remove all
of these
once we remove all of these we just need
to use a for loop and see
for to do
okay right here in our view.py let's
name this to do's
so we can say for to do introduce
so for to do in to do's
then let's end our for loop right here
so let's end four
and four and then right here we're just
gonna say
to do
dots title
we can save this come back here and
refresh now as you can see it gives us
everything in which we have right here
so go for a wrong code code go for a run
boy is reversed so if i click on
something and i'll say
it's the gym the gym
and save it you can see it's
automatically added
on the list but is on the bottom so
we want the newer to do to be on top
for us to do this we're just going to
come here as if
to do introduce reversed
when we save this and come here you see
there's a latest dice on top
so let's just do something like it
now you can see it is on the top let's
say sleep
now you can see sleep is on the top so
that's basically how to
um showcase a list in
django ginger formats just using the
reverse attribute
very easy so now that we have these let
me just add one more
let me say one more attribute which is
as you can see that this everything is
in small letter
so we want that even if a user writes it
in let me say
small letter like buy
buy or close so as you can see the user
started this with
the b as a small letter so once it's
shown here we want it to be calculator
for us to do this we're just going to
come here
use this and say title
this alone once you refresh as you can
see everything nice and caps later
so that's also a good attribute which
might be useful
in some of your projects so now that's
good
what we just need to do now which i
think is the last thing
is that once the user come here clicks
on delete we want
whatever is here to be deleted
also very easy we're gonna come back
here
so we're going to create a new url and
then let's name this url delete
so i'm going to say path
let's name it delete but this url right
here
is going to be a dynamic url and this is
because it's taking an
input so what we want to delete
it to do that to do is going to have an
id
which is being sent to this delete url
so for this url to collect that id we
need to use a dynamic url so we need to
pass in a variable
i'm going to say slash let's give it a
string
and let's say pk like this
so after doing this we can continue to
our normal format which is views
dot delete and then we can say
name equals to delete
so this is nice now we can come into our
views
and create a new function
and name it delete
take a request and after taking a
request you should take pk
and pk is the variable which we assigned
here that is a string
so when i'm writing an html page what we
want to do
is to just get a particular object
from the module so first to do this i
just gonna say
to do should now be equals to
to do dots
objects dot
get the one in which the id
is equals to pk
so now once we get that we just want to
say
to do the delete
and then once it has deleted it then we
want to return
redirect direct the user back to the
home page
so what we're doing here now you guys
are going to see how we're going to send
the id into this view
so let me explain in detail
when you create an object in a model in
django
automatically each object has an id so
this code which is the first object i
created has an id of zero
this go for a run has an id of one it's
the gym as an id of two and so on like
that
so each of them has a unique id which is
being
assigned to them so that unique id once
i click on delete
the any kind is going to be used to know
which to do the user wants to delete so
as i click on delete that id
is going to be sent into this url
and then it's going to be saved into pk
which is this variable
then we're going to collect that
variable name pk
into this view then what we're doing
right here is that
we're saying to do dot object.get so
this to do
is our module in our database
and then we're saying does get the one
in which the id
is equal to pk and as you know pk is the
id in which we sent into this view
so i'm basically getting the id which
the user wants to delete
and then we're storing that particular
object into
a variable called to do so once we
already know
what design was to delete we just use
the attribute to do the delete
it deletes it and then we return user
back to the home page
so now let's go back and see
now let's refresh this so let's click on
delete
nothing happens this is because we've
known it's assigned
the variable let me show you how to do
this i'm just gonna come here
right here in our index where we see
delete
so this delete now has to be a link
so i'm just gonna give it a link
a and then let's paste delete in there
now let's say hyperlink
so we're gonna use the jungle format
and then we're gonna say delete
and then i want to say to do dot
id so once we save this everything
should work
so let's come back here refresh
okay it says um invalid
right here so the reason why it's
invalid is because
it says delete expected empty or n4 did
you forget to load this type
so what we just need to do is to come
here
if i shift to this side you guys can see
that the area is coming from
right here so the problem is the way in
which we pass this url
so you can also pass this url by saying
[Music]
delete slash
will say to do dot id
once we save it and go back let's make
sure we have everything correct
now once we refresh we shouldn't be
seeing this arrow now you can see that
this delete is showing as a link
we will take the of that later but now
let's click on delete and see what
happens
as you guys can see that particular to
do is gone
let's click on the next one that is gone
click on this
it's gone and then let's also try to add
jog you can see it's there once i click
on delete
it's gone so that's basically how to
build a basic to-do list app
so now let's just take care of this blue
link which is showing there
first to do this we're just going to use
a basic css we're going to say
style equals to text decoration
so say text decoration should be none
so this css is going to remove all the
text decoration which is assigned to a
link
so once we refresh you guys can see that
it doesn't have that line on diet again
but the color is still blue so also very
easy we're just going to come here and
say
color okay shift
back right in this style
i'm going to say color should be black
let's save this refresh
now you can see that the color is black
and once we hit on delete
everything still works successfully
delete again
still works successfully now let's just
test on our app once again
so now we can add a new
to do let's say it's the gym to enter
oh we've added that before so let's just
delete that
and let's just say learn flask
so click on enter as you can see
it brings up this length flask and it
brings it up
the latest side of the table
of the list i mean and we can also
delete and one feature which we added if
we
put in small letter it's automatically
going to show it in calculator
so i hope you guys learned something
from
this tutorial section if you did please
don't forget to smash the like button
and please subscribe
now that we've successfully completed
our app what we just need to do
is to host our app on iroku it's very
easy to do this
we just need to make sure we have some
python libraries installed
and these python libraries are gunikon
and jango hiroku
so let's go ahead and install them beep
install
unicorn and jungle heroku
so i already have this installed it's
going to tell me requirement already
satisfied
but i just needed to show you how to
install those libraries so you should go
ahead and install on your computer
so now that we have that installed what
we need to do is to come into our roots
directory let's close all these
now root directory we're going to create
a new file name it runtime.txt
in that runtime.txt what we need right
there is our python version so the
python version which we use for this
project is what we're looking for
to get that we'll come to our terminal
and type
python version
python two iphones with version so as
you can see
i am using python 3.7.4
so i'm going to say python then i'm
going to say
iphone 3.7.4 so that's the
way you should write your version let's
just save it
and then quit this file the next thing
we need to do now is to create a new
file
let's make sure we close this and these
files must be in the root directory
the root directory means the directory
which contain the
money money.py file so that's the root
directory of any django project
so now in the root directory we're going
to create a new file and name it proc
file
with no extension so proc file like this
and what you go in here is a piece of
code now this is how the code is
so instead of these these are like a
line of clothes boilerplates something
like that
so instead of contactless is the name of
your app so it should be
um to-do list so that's how it should be
web unicorn to-do list.wsgi
column application two items log one
iphone
file space and iphone so that's what
should go into this file
then we're gonna save this file so after
having this done
what we just need to do is to come into
our terminal
and press beep freeze
requirement requirements.txt
now when we press enter a new file here
is created named requirement.txt
what is in that file is all the pattern
libraries in which we used in this
project
so after doing that now we're going to
come into our settings.py
file and then we're going to add some
things
so up here we have to import
django heroku
django iroku and the second thing we
need to import is dj database url
import dj underscore database url
so the next thing we need to do is go
into that our database
and then change it from sqlite we're
going to change it to the
database in which eroku is going to
recognize
so i'm going to change this defaults
not going to be an array or at least
it's going to be dj
database url dot config
now this is how it should be i'm just
gonna press save
the next thing i need to do right now is
to go down
into my project right here i'm gonna say
jungle
heroku then dot settings
boom bracket locales then open bracket
close bracket
now i'm going to save this file again
the last thing we're doing in this file
is to go to allow hosts and just press
these to allow all hosts like this
so once we save it we're done with this
file
now after doing all this thing we can
now start
with our command line that is with our
iroku so we need to say iroku
login
so what's going to happen now is that
it's going to prompt us to
click on something and then it's going
to open our default browser
and then in there we're going to log
into heroku automatically
so when i click on login if you tell me
logged in you can close this page and
return to your cli
so once i close this page and go back
you can see now it automatically logs me
in
so what i just need to do now is to say
heroku
create and let me say to do
list so once i create this to-do list
it's automatically going to create this
to-do list app
in my roku account
so once it creates that we're just going
to start
with the git so as you can see it's
creating okay it says to the list
already created
my mind wasn't really there so let me
just say to do list let me just give you
random words
like seven ways nine
so let's see i don't think that should
be taken
okay it's creating yeah it's created
so all we need to do nice is just say
git status
okay then we're gonna say git init
so now he's going to initialize the
repository and let's say git status
again
now we should give us something right
and then we're going to say
git remotes iphone v
nice i want to say nice git remote
add heroku
now i want to add we're going to scroll
up right here
when we created the app you see it gave
us two url i'm going to take the second
url
which has dot git at the end scroll down
and paste that so it's going to be git
remote add iroku then that url
so i'm going to click on enter so now
i'm just gonna say git remote v
again so that's nice and i'm gonna say
git
status
okay nice so now what i want to do is to
create our database
on our cloud so i'm going to say iroku
add-ons i'm going to say column
create i'm going to say
iroku i think
postgres
ql then column i'm saying
obi dev
so that's what i need to see so i think
this should be an iphone
so now once i click on enter it should
run that command line so let's wait for
a response
okay so it's creating see i couldn't
find a service named of the dev
okay there's a typographical error i put
two
o's instead of 2b so let's
wait for that and let's see
should create that for us in some
seconds
okay nice so it says database has been
created and it's available the database
is empty
okay nice so the database has been
successfully created
so now that we have our database created
what we just need to do is to commit
so we're just going to say git add
and then after adding we say git commit
i think m
then i'm gonna say the
first time
and then let's close that now when we
click on
enter we're gonna commit that so that's
nice
then as for the last step we're just
gonna say git
push iroku master
okay um there was typographically right
there so i don't think it will work
so let's just wait for that to give us
an error then we're going to say git
push
iroku master okay so
remove these and it should be git so git
push iroku master
now this is going to deploy everything
which you've been doing
on the url in which it created
area let me show you the url of the app
so when we are creating we will come
here when we created
these uh which is to do list789 you see
it gave us this url right here
so once it deploys it it's going to
deploy it on this url
so once it's done and click on this url
what we're going to see
is this app in which we've been building
since so let's scroll down and see how
far the deployment is going
okay it gave us an error
if we come back here so the reason for
that error
it says now this is very good because
you know also know how to debug
so it says request runtime is not
available for this stack
heroku 20. okay that's nice so what we
just need to do right here is to come
into runtime.txt so the reason why we're
getting that error is because of
our runtime so uh python
version is too low for heroku 20.
so if i scroll up here you're going to
see that it says heroku 20 stack
so it's going to update to one of the
latest versions we'll say 3.9.1
and then what we just need to do is to
commit those changes
so i'm just going to say git add
and then git commit and then we're just
going to say git push iroku master
now this shouldn't give us any errors
again
so let's just give it a few seconds
installing python
nice so everything is working
so because iroquois has been upgraded to
europe
20 the stack is now 20 that's why we're
getting that error
so notice that if you are using django
and you like deploying on your roku you
need to be using
python 3.9 version to be specific
so let's just give it a few seconds to
deploy okay installing collected
packages
nice okay
so just gonna wait so it should be done
in a few seconds because all the main
stuffs are done already
so you should just deploy it to our url
yes done
yes so it's deployed to eroku as you can
see this
link is deployed to your roku so let's
just wait for
the last confirmation and then it's
going to opt out of that
command so let's wait for it
okay nice so now let's click on this url
so let's open the link once we open the
link
we should just see our app it says um
programming error
so anytime in which you are dealing with
database and then you just deployed your
app
you need to also make migrations just
the way you make migration once you
change your model.p wi-fi
i'm just going to come in here say
heroku
run python
manage the py make migrations
and then after making migrations we're
just gonna say by
heroku run python menu.py
migrate so that's going to do and solve
all the problems
so let's give it a second to run that
okay
running python monitor py make
migrations
so that should run that within no time
running still running
okay no change is detected so let's just
migrate
so now once this migrates successfully
we're just gonna go refresh our link and
then we should see our to-do list app
so let's wait and see
okay see my creating let's see
up run and then go yes so that's nice
let's just wait nice so now once we come
here and then refresh
we shouldn't see any error so as you
guys can see
it says jungle to-do list up now we can
just
add and say it's the gym
and once you press enter you see it's
added already and we can say
code added
you can say uh take a run
and it should be added so as you guys
can see everything is working perfectly
let me just try to delete one
so let's click on delete and you guys
can see that it's gone
so everything is working perfectly it's
hosted online the database is connected
and i walked you guys through all these
steps so thank you for watching this
session of the video
and you can go to this url to check it
out live
is live now and i'm not taking it down
thank you for watching once again
in this part of the tutorial we're going
to be building
an english dictionary using django so
user is going to be able to search for a
word and get the meaning of that word
the synonyms and the antonyms of that
word also so let's start by installing
django
we say peep install jungle
and then you should tell me requirements
already satisfied jungle
admin start up
stat project
and let's name it english
dictionary
so let's move into english dictionary
and then let's start an app a jungle app
and let's name the dictionary
so now when i press dir i should see
money dot py english dictionary and then
dictionary
so let me come into visual studio code
and then open this project i just
created i'm going to click on open
folder
and then right here all i just need to
do to select this folder
and then it should open in my editor
so now that i have these let me just
start configuring
the first thing i need to do is to
create a new folder in here and name it
templates
so this template folder is going to
contain all our html files
so let me just move in the html file for
this project
let me move it into visual studio code
so now that we have that in there what i
just need to do is to go to
english dictionary then settings.py
and i'm just going to go down a little
bit
and right here i'm going to say based
there
based on the score there then slash
templates
now this is just to tell jungle where
our html files are located
after doing this i just need to do the
url mapping
so i'm going to come into dictionary i'm
going to create a new file
urls.py in there i'm going to say from
django dot urls
import path and after i put in these
i'll say url buttons
equals to pass
and now save views dot index
and let me give you the name of index
so let me first import views before i'm
able to use it
so i say from roots import views
so i'm going to go into views folder now
and create a new function named index
so i'm going to say def index
it's going to take a request
and then i'm gonna render this html page
in this template folder
so i'll say return render
request
index.html
okay let's make sure this is correct
index.html
so before uh index.html can show
us our own page we also need to come
into the project folder
and open urls.py right here we need to
import
include
after importing include then we're going
to say
path
then include
i'm gonna say dictionary
dot urls then i'm gonna save it
now i can quit this let me just open a
new terminal
and then what i need to do now is just
to run my project
now when i run this project my html that
i rendered
is going to show as the home page so let
me open up my browser
and then i'm going to open up my
localhost in my browser
so let me open up localhost
so now it should show me my project
as you can see it shows me this simple
html page with just a form
so this is what we need to build the
dictionary very simple
so you are just going to type in a watch
once you click on search
it's going to say the meaning and
synonyms of the word right here
so let's simply do that this is very
very easy
what we just need to do now is to first
of all
create a new view
and let's name it watch
let's say requests
and let's say return render
request and then we're going to create
another html page let's name it
word.html we've now created it now but
we're going to create it so let's save
it for now
and let's also create a new view name it
word
let's save let's go back to our views
this should be returned
then let's save this
so in our urls since it's a list
you should have a comma so after doing
that we're just going to come into
templates
and let's first create a new file let's
name it word.html
now we're going to leave this file blank
for now let's close
this terminal now in this index
what we want to do is to make this a
form
so i'm going to scroll down
right here let me first say
h2 search
for a word
so let's see the changes okay it shows
but not
pretty cool so let's leave it so what i
want to do now
is to make sure that this is a form so
i'm going to say
form and then we're going to close the
form
after this button
like this so what i want to do after
closing the form after the button we're
just going to say
action
and this action is going to the word url
like this
now we must make sure that these inputs
have a name which it doesn't know
so now i'm just going to say name
should be equals to search
so this is the search term in which it
is accessed then it's going to be
submitted into this word
so i'm just going to come right here
in the views i'm going to get that word
we're going to say search
equals to request
dot get that get
and we're going to say word i think it's
search
so what this is must be the name
which you are assigning to the input
that's why i intentionally put a name
field here
because that we're going to use to get
whatever the user searched for
so now that we have this how are we
going to get
the name the meaning synonyms and
antonym
so i'm going to use a python library
called pi dictionary
so let me bring up my time now here real
quick
let me open a new terminal
so first to install this
module we need to type peep
install
by dictionary
so i have it installed it should tell me
requirement already satisfied
but for you you should go ahead and
install it as you can see stage
requirement already satisfied
so let me go back to my normal time now
and quit so what i just need to do right
here is to import this library
so i'm just going to save from
pi dictionary import
by dictionary now that i have this
imported
i'm just gonna say dictionary
should be equal to
by dictionary with brackets
so now that we have the search which is
also the word
we're just going to get the meaning and
storage in a variable name meaning
so same meaning equals to
dictionary
dot meaning
of this search
so that's the meaning and then we're
also going to do the same thing for
synonyms
it will be equal to dictionary
just synonym
of the search i'm going to do a similar
thing for the answer names
so anthony's will be equals to
dictionary
that antonyms
of the search so this is how to simply
do it
and after doing this what we just need
to do is to
put it in a context
so in here i'm just gonna say
the meaning
so the meaning should be equals to the
meaning because the antonym
the
and we are going to pass all this into
our
html so meaning should be meaning
comma they just copied
i'll say synonyms should be synonyms
and antonyms also
should be antonyms
so we can just pass this right here and
say context
and let's save so now once we save this
and we come into our word.html
what i want us to do is just copy all
these
paste it right here and then
what i want to do now is that under here
we want to write the meaning and i don't
need the synonyms of the word
so that would be under the button under
the form
so let's say meaning let's give it like
an h3
let's say meaning now should be equals
to
meaning
so now let's just test meaning before we
continue
so let's just save this
and then what i want to do is to come
here
into our browser and refresh so let's
search for
it and then let's click on search
and once we click on search as you guys
can see it takes us to
another page what search equals it
says meaning equals all of these so what
i want to do we just want to get
only the first meaning we don't need to
rest and
we need to pass this css right here
so i'm going to come into a visual
studio code
and then right here in the word
instead of putting it right here
i'm just going to put it outside to wrap
and then in views dot py
meaning will be meaning
a noun
like this and the first one
zero so we can test this
again so once we go to the home page
it should take us yeah so let's search
for
it again and then once we click on
search
she take us to the words page and now we
say key error at
noun okay
so the what is simply saying is that in
the dictionary that this is bringing
back
there is no key named noun so we just
need to patch that
so that is because
it is not unknown so we can basically do
that
in plenty other ways but for now
let's just search for set
and then let's see as you guys can see
meaning a group of things of the same
kind
that belong together and are you so used
so
that's how to get the meaning of the
word so we also want to get
the synonyms and antennas so i'm just
going to use
a for loop right here so i'm going to
say
exactly the same thing
and say 4.
4 let's come into our views and get what
we passed
signal name in synonyms
so you just want to pass in the synonym
and then what we just want to do
is to end for
and i'm also going to do the same thing
for the answer names
let's delete these copy this
and paste so let's try
for the answer names also
so in the word
say to be for antonym
in antonyms then this should be antonym
then n4 so let's go back and see
so if you just refresh this page we
should see the meaning
with the antonym and synonyms okay as
you guys can see
if i scroll okay so
it's basically just listing everything
out so we just need to pass that and
let it just put it in a word
so first of all this is not meaning
what we need to do now is this bring
this in here
i want to bring it into the hdre tag
instead of outside
so i'm gonna do like these and just end
four same thing we're gonna do here
into the h3 tag i'm also going to end
for
in the h3 tag
so that's what we want to do so right
here also we want to say
synonyms
and then right here i want to say
antonyms before the for loop
so let's just give it caps later
and we can save once you come back here
and refresh this page now
we should see it aligned horizontally
as you guys can see meaning a group of
things of the same kind that belong
together and are so used
synonyms best no good put inlay and a
lot of synonyms so we just want to use
comma
to separate each of them so i'm just
going to put comma right here and also
comma right here
so just press that and once we refresh
we should see comma
so that everything will be refined so as
you can see
meaning a group of things of the same
kind that belong to
together and are so used so synonyms it
gives us all the synonyms antonyms
also give us all the antonyms so let's
search for
english the session for the meaning
and then we should see the meaning
synonyms as you can see it says meaning
an indo european language and also give
us synonyms
and then the antonyms so that's how to
build an english dictionary using jungle
i hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
now that we finished building this
project what we need to do
is to deploy it online so for us to do
this we need to have two live
item libraries installed and these
libraries are
unicorn and django heroku so to install
them you save
python install pip install
gunikon and django
i think heroku so i already have them
installed you should tell me
requirements already satisfied but for
you you should go ahead and install that
so now the next thing we need to do is
to go into our roots directory
and create a new file named runtime.txt
so in this runtime.txt what is going to
be in there is the python version in
which you are using
so mine is python
3.9.1
so i'm just going to save this and then
what i need to do now is to create
another file named
prog file
and then what is going to go in here is
a file
is this code so it changes project
to the name of your project which mine
is english
dictionary so you can save this file now
and close it so after doing this the
next thing you need to do
is to come into your terminal and say
peep
freeze
requirements
dot txt
now you'll notice that you're going to
create a new file here
that's because it's storing all the
libraries in which we used in this
project
so now let's come into settings.py
we're going to go to database okay
since we are not using database in this
video we don't need to configure
anything for database
but what we just need to go is come up
import jungle
iroku and then scroll down
allow us let's allow
all us and then we're going to scroll
down to the bottom
i say jungle heroku
dot settings
locus and open bracket close bracket
after doing this i'm just going to come
into my
command line and say heroku login
so now it's going to prompt me to open
my default browser
and then log into iroku from there
so it should give me an option like
press any
key to open your browser or press q to
quit so if you press any key
it's going to open your browser if you
press q it's going to quit
like you can see so if i press h it's
going to open up my default browser
like this and then log in
now i'm logged in if i go back in there
you can see that i'm now logged in
so what i just need to do now is to
create an uroku app so i'll say heroku
create and let me name it english
dictionary
white
so right now it should create that app
and then give me two urls
one is the url to the git repository
and the other is url to
my app so now that we have this
we're just gonna say git status
okay and we're going to initialize it by
saying git init
and then git status again
and now i'm just going to say git remote
v and then adjusting say
git remote
add heroku
and then we're going to add that giz
repository right here
so i'm just going to copy it
come down and paste it nice
so i'm going to say git remove v again
nice and then we're going to take git
status
so what i just need to do now is to just
say git add
i'm going to say git commit
let me see the first time
enter and then i'm just going to say git
push heroku
master
so now it's going to deploy it to iroku
so i'm just going to give it a couple of
seconds to
deploy our project onto your roku
it doesn't take too long depending on
how large a project is
so let's see okay it's working
so everything is going on fine right now
i'm just gonna give it a couple of
seconds install
yes installing collected packages
okay
compressing after compressing it should
say done yes so it has said done
that means it has been deployed so i'm
just going to wait for the last
confirmation and then it's going to opt
out of
this command so let's just wait for that
confirmation and then we're going to
open this
up so don't so when i click on control
and click it's going to open up in my
browser
so as you guys can see it opened it up
so let's just search for
english
so when we search for english you guys
can see brought out the mini
synonyms and antonyms so let's search
for another thing like spots
so as you guys can see what are the
meaning synonyms and antonyms so that's
how to build a busy
english dictionary using jungle so we've
hosted this
you can go to this url now to view it if
you enjoy this
part of the video don't forget to like
it and smash the like button
and if you have any question please drop
it in the comments
so guys that's gonna be the end of this
video thank you so much for watching to
this part
if you like this video once again please
don't forget to smash the like button
and please subscribe and if you like
more videos like this
i'm building more projects on web
development with python jungle and stuff
like that
you can also check out my channel at
code with tomi having that said
bye for now